let's take a live look at capitol hill
where a new congress is going to be
sworn in
for a rare sunday session that's
tomorrow as lawmakers call for even more
stimulus my next guest
is a newly elected congress congressman
will he support it
august fluger is the republican
congressman elect from the state of
texas
he is an air force veteran we are very
proud of him he fought
and flew uh against isis in both iraq
and
syria good to see you congressman elect
thanks for coming here congratulations
our first and foremost are you for that
two thousand dollar check instead of the
six hundred dollar check
well thank you for having me this
morning and as has been mentioned that's
something that is being taken up in this
current congress and so
you know any new provisions or new bills
i want to see the
the details and understand what it is
that is going to be helping the
working-class americans of no fault of
their own small businesses have been
shut down people are in lockdown
i'm very proud of the judges and the
mayors in my district for taking the
precautions to keep folks
safe during the pandemic but also to
fight to keep our businesses open and
really that's the larger question is
we need to get back to work we have a
vaccine that is working hard uh we need
the country and the economy to get back
well we we certainly do but the the
point is is that a lot of people are
suffering terribly and
and uh according to one poll about 80
percent of americans
uh favor that 2000 over the 600 check
and there is a further question about
how
mcconnell's maneuverings to not vote on
it before the georgia election
will affect the georgia election are you
concerned about that
well we're concerned about the georgia
election for sure and yes you're right
there are many americans who are
suffering
uh that need help that targeted help um
and they need
programs like ppp to help their their
businesses get back to normal so yeah
we'll have to see how it unfolds and
obviously has been stated on your show
already a turnout in georgia is going to
be key
um we need folks to get out and to vote
for
mr purdue ms leffler to keep the senate
and to keep it read
now as i mentioned you were you are a
proud veteran of
of the wars in the middle east you flew
uh you were active for 20 years in the
air force you were
actually i believe still a lieutenant
colonel in the reserves am i right on
that
i'm a colonel in the reserves that's
absolutely right and you were on
president trump's security council i'm
curious what do you think
is the greatest security threat to the
united states right now
well no doubt it's china on so many
different levels and president trump
rightfully three years ago pivoted our
focus to china
this this existential threat this great
power competition i'm very worried about
the incoming administration and their
lack of focus
and so we'll be watching very closely
their cabinet picks to make sure
that they are focused on china because
it's certainly a focus of mine of my
colleagues
in the military and of people who have
been in the national security business
and we're going to be watching very
closely to see what their actions are
i would imagine that you were quite
concerned that a member of the house
intel committee uh who had no experience
to be on that committee when he was
appointed by the way uh was compromised
by a chinese communist spy
well it's just absolutely uh disgusting
to think that somebody could be
compromised and be on the house intel
committee
uh hunter biden's dealings with chinese
businesses i mean all of these things
lead us to believe
that there is a lack of focus that there
is a real lack of concern about china as
a threat
which is why this incoming class of 43
freshmen the most diverse
class in the history with more women
more minorities more veterans
uh very proud of this class they have
the focus we are going to be
fighting for our districts fighting for
this country for our security
very quickly uh are you going to try to
get on that house intel committee you
certainly have the credentials for it
uh unlike mr swalwell um will you get on
it and do you recommend that he resign
from that committee
well for sure i recommend that he resign
and we'll see whether or not i get on
that committee
but my focus will be first and foremost
for my district for the national
security items
that we represent which include oil and
gas agriculture
and the military and so anybody that
doesn't have those
agenda items that's on that committee
that uh and including mr swahwell
needs to resign for something that uh
that is clearly a compromise
uh in a contradiction of upholding our
constitution
congressman elect august fluger uh thank
you for your service sir
we're glad to have you as a member of
the congress appreciate it
thank you